there are so few people voting in LA
that there are now people talking about
paying people to vote and giving them
prizes to vote LA Times had an
interesting piece on this let's look at
a quote maybe it's $25,000 maybe it's
fifty thousand dollars that's where the
pilot program comes in to figure out
what number and amount of prizes would
actually get people to the voting box
that's Nathan Hochman the Los Angeles
Ethics Commission President so yeah
voting has been going precipitously down
in Los Angeles our current mayor in Los
Angeles Eric Garcetti got twelve percent
of the eligible voters actually voted
for him that means twelve percent of the
people walking around in LA actually
voted for the guy that's running the
show let's look at some numbers on how
the voting is fallen off so in 1969 in
the mayoral campaign seventy-six percent
of the eligible voters voted that's
pretty decent for a democracy I wish we
could get that in our in our
presidential voting then in a march two
thousand nine primary for mayor 17.9
percent voted and then jun 2013 we had a
mayoral run off which is what Eric
Garcetti 120 three-point-three percent
of the eligible voters vote report he
got around 51% or something so twelve
percent of the people in LA voted for
this guy so voting is a major problem I
have long said we voting election day
should be a national holiday every year
people have to go to work yep let's
remove that from the equation let's get
people voting i think that would be one
simple way of fixing this but paying
people and prizes this is just a big
game show now is America just a big old
game show with that it's unfortunate
that we need you know a game show to
incentivizes to vote but it's somewhat
understandable Dave I think that we're
so disillusioned with the system that we
don't think our vote matters it kind of
doesn't right we know that when we have
corporations that can have can give
unlimited donations to political
candidates are you know vote gonna be
pretty insignificant now in terms of
giving people money don't I find it
absolutely I'm ridiculous but I think
it's some out-of-the-box thinking and it
you know it might get some people out to
the voting polls now who's gonna go to
the voting polls right
that's that's a question that I would
ask if you're offering say $25,000 some
people might think oh I could really use
that money I'm gonna go and vote whereas
others might think it $25,000 is not
gonna make a difference but yet others
who are educated on the statistics are
gonna do the math and be like it's not
really in a mess right so it literally
would be like it would be like Lana
they're not just handing out 25 grand to
go vote like exactly so I think you
would have a very specific portion of
the population showing up to the polls
and that might actually influence the
way we with the way we vote and also the
results of the election so that I think
would be interesting and also say and
then it could just backfire you could
have so many people show up that the
lines are longer and now people don't
want to wait until more people leave
like this could just be a shitshow yeah
good problem to have how sad is the
state of democracy in general like when
you see these things about the voting
you know to me like we're all the
political world the news world like we
talk about this stuff all the time
obviously set the money and politics
thing is big for all the stuff that we
do around here but how just sad is just
the generals like people just don't vote
they just don't believe it works they
just they don't believe so it's not
about money it's like about belief yeah
and it's like even if you do vote even
if you if the person you voted for gets
into office you still feel like you're
not gonna get the result you want so why
even bother but it is particularly sad
especially as a black woman because you
know it wasn't that long ago when we
couldn't vote and so a lot of times and
you know we have to fight so hard to get
the right to vote so it's very upsetting
to know that it's trivialized and it's
just that privilege is just like I don't
care anymore people literally died for
us to be able to vote and to know that
people aren't going to the polls because
they don't feel like it it's it's I
can't even believe it yeah how much of
this is education though because I feel
like when there's a presidential
election you know we always get it the
uptick in numbers so we get something
like sixty percent I think Obama's first
go-round it was really good like seventy
percent I don't don't call me on that
exactly uh but then in the off years
it's ridiculous I mean we literally are
getting like twenty percent and
something like that for so this year
were in an off year 2014 an off year so
we're gonna be able to vote for Congress
and the vote the turn is gonna be
terrible despite the fact
they have like a seven percent approval
rating so this is really just about
education right it's education and it's
um it's almost the exposure like a lot
of people that I know don't even realize
its voting day yeah and so when it's the
presidency there's a commercial every
five seconds but a lot of times you
don't get the information which is the
education you don't understand who your
options are you don't understand all of
the proposals that you're voting on and
people aren't taking the time to do the
research and really read through all of
the rigmarole because it comes out to
the fact that they just don't think it
matters yeah so for the money are good
okay well the money in politics thing do
they just have a vested interest in not
having people vote and that's really
what's going on here interest not having
certain people vote they're trying to
make sure that the the people that are
gonna vote in their favor vote and those
who don't don't and this is why when you
mention education I don't necessarily
think it's all about education I think
the biggest contributing factor here is
awareness particularly through media as
you alluded to Vanessa right so when we
get commercials and propaganda I think
that's what really moves a needle when
we instill fear that if we don't vote
for a particular candidate that other
candidate will leave us jobless and
we'll lose our homes like this type of a
misinformation is I think what really
pushes people to vote um so education
has definitely has a partner but when
people are really educated I would argue
if some say forget the system I'm not
part of it I'm leaving the US or why
vote if it doesn't matter well said I'm
pretty sure if you just gave out ps4s
people would start voting a massive
record number